today on the ben shapiro show we
broadcast live from the march for life
and debunk the most common pro-choice
arguments one by one
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
alrighty so today on the benchmark show
we are live from the march for life you
can hear
the thousands of amazing people who have
come out hours earlier
standing out here in the freezing cold
weather i'm told this is temperate balmy
weather for washington dc this time of
year but i'm from california so i don't
know what these people are talking about
it is amazing to be here it's really an
honor to be here we're going to do
something we've never done before on the
bench shapiro show we're doing
a full-on themed hour of the ben shapiro
show we're doing nothing but debunking
pro-choice arguments all hour long
and also we have a special guest who's
going to be calling in a little bit
later to say hello
to everyone who is here so let's just
jump right in because there are a lot of
pro-choice arguments to debunk so
let's begin with this we now live in a
country that is still debating over
whether abortion
is a moral good or a moral evil
president obama
back on the 41st anniversary of the
debacle the evil decision known as roe
vs wade
he said quote tonight as we reflect on
the 41st anniversary
of the supreme court decision in roe v
white we recommit ourselves to the
decisions guiding principle
that every woman should be able to make
her own choices about her body and her
health
this is a country where everyone
deserves the same freedom and
opportunities to fulfill their dreams
my roe versus wade is a grand and
glorious thing because now women have
the ability to fulfill their dreams by
killing babies which is an odd position
i mean the position that you actually
are only able to engage fully in freedom
if you have the ability to snuff out an
unborn life is a weird position but
this was not unusual for president obama
you recall that a few years back
president obama spoke
before the nasty terrible organization
known as planned parenthood
at the very end of his speech as you
recall president obama actually said
that god should bless planned parenthood
here's what that sounded like
as long as we've got a fight to make
sure women have access to quality
affordable health care and as long as
we've got to fight to protect a woman's
right to make her own choices
about her own health i want you to know
that you've also got a president
who's going to be right there with you
fighting every step of the way
thank you planned parenthood god bless
you
you know we've gotten a lot of flack i
know the march for life has gotten a lot
of flack for allowing me to broadcast
from the stage because i'm a political
partisan because
i don't hide the fact that i'm
conservative but the fact is
that the pro-life issue does not have to
be a partisan issue the only reason that
there are so many folks who believe that
it has to be a partisan issue is because
unfortunately one party in this country
has decided to embrace the full on
abortion until point of birth
position all right so
[Applause]
now back to the issue at hand there's a
piece in the washington post suggesting
that it was very bad that i was going to
be here today because it makes the issue
partisan it is not
my fault or your fault for the fault of
the unborn that president obama chose to
take the position
that he chose that is his fault okay and
it's not anybody else's fault
when people in one party decide
overwhelmingly to excise pro-life voices
from their midst
i know that there is a couple of
democrats at least one democrat is going
to be speaking
at the march today which is fantastic i
wish all democrats were here at the
march today
but there has been a shift inside the
far left and
increasingly the main left mainstream
left version
of what abortion should be about so if
you go all the way back to the early 90s
the position of the democratic party
which is still quote-unquote pro-choice
which is of course a euphemism
the the original position was safe legal
and rare right you recall hillary
clinton said this back when she was
first lady of the united states
the way she articulated abortion was
safe legal and rare here's what that
sounded like
we can support a woman's right to choose
that makes abortion safe legal and rare
and reduces the number of abortions
okay well that happens to not be the
position of the democratic party today
first of all that was never logically
tenable
right if you want something to be safe
and legal then your suggestion is that
there really isn't
anything morally wrong with the act
that's that's taking place if abortion
is not morally wrong
then why should it be rare so if you
want it to be safe and legal then why
exactly should it be rare
obviously once you say it should be rare
you're acknowledging that there is a
moral wrong that is being done
at some level and therefore the case for
being legal is actually a lot weaker
particularly when what you're talking
about is not
some sort of consensual behavior you're
talking about the taking of an unborn
life
but the new position of the democratic
party increasingly and at least a lot of
folks on the mainstream left
is not even safe legal in a rare they've
moved beyond that now we are in the
shout your abortion era you have folks
like lena dunham
who i'll just leave it there
she says she says literally she said
this in the last
couple of years she said that she wish
she'd had an abortion
this is what it sounded like now i can
say that i still haven't had an abortion
but i wish i had i mean that's an
amazing statement it has become a right
of passage for people
a way of showing of signaling to people
that you
are a good women's rights advocate
to suggest that you wish you had an
abortion i mean imagine the moral evil
that it takes
to be able to say that you wished that
you had had conceived a child just to
kill that baby in your womb so that then
you could brag to all of your friends
about what a good feminist you were
it's an amazing incredible disgusting
thing okay so this position has changed
radically
now i don't want to take on the kind of
straw man position that
democrats are are all the most radical
people on earth i want to take on the
most mainstream
arguments that are made against the
pro-life position
and we're going to go through these one
by one they're basically 10 of these
pro-choice
arguments and all of them are meritless
all of them are maryland so we're going
to go through them and then i hope by
the end of the show that folks are going
to be equipped
to speak more honestly and truthfully
about
how this how these issues work so
argument number one
is that this isn't a human being it's
not a human life this is the argument
that was put out
by the editor of some publication called
romper which i'd never heard of
but earlier this week this this tweet
was put up in which
when you showed the tweet in which this
romper editor
suggested dear scotus supreme court
fetal tissue is not a person fetal
tissue is not a person fetal tissue's
not a person fetal tissue is not a
person fetal tissue is not a person
but i am and i matter more than fetal
tissue sign people who have miscarriages
and abortions
so there are many many logical problems
with this position number one
to lump in people who have miscarriages
with people who have abortions is in and
of itself disgusting
there are many many women who want their
babies who had miscarriages
the idea that they didn't consider their
own children children because they had a
miscarriage because it was just fetal
tissue is just
absolute garbage it is absolute nonsense
this also happens to be a scientific
now if she had said that fetal stem
cells are not the same as adult stem
cells of course that's true
that's not what she's saying she's
saying fetal tissue meaning the tissue
of a fetus
is not a person okay well by that
standard human flesh is not a person
it's true a person being a person
requires more than you just being
a bag of flesh right you have to be
alive right you have to be living but
there is no distinction whatsoever
between the flesh of a baby one minute
before it
enters the vaginal canal and one minute
after it exits the vaginal canal the
vaginal canal does not magically confer
personhood
it's just sheer nonsense and it's even
more nonsensical when folks suggest
that basically it's just a cluster of
meaningless cells from the very
beginning
now today's theme of the march for life
is that it is a march for science right
is that science is what matters
[Music]
and this is why it's amazing you see the
media will cover this march there's a
bunch of religious bigots out there
trying to end women's rights that's how
the if they cover it at all right
there are there'll be hundreds of
thousands of people who show up today
and they'll be like 9 000 people who
show up tomorrow
at the women's march and they'll cover
the women's march endlessly and they'll
probably ignore for the most part the
march for life but if they do cover it
they will fail to acknowledge
that the actual rationale for the
pro-life position
is not religious in nature we'll talk
about religion but it's not but it's not
really religious in nature
the actual pro-life position is based on
the sheer unadulterated science of human
life
so let's go through that science for a
second
so let's begin with week one right week
one of
of pregnancy this or at least this is at
conception
right we have some graphics that we can
put up here if you take a look
at what uh what fertilization looks like
at the start of the week
ovulation happens the egg is fertilized
and at that point
human life begins there's no question
that a human life has now begun
if you were to find this on another
planet it would be considered a life
right you would say life found on mars
if you found this organism on another
planet
it would be a life this is a human life
now the question is whether it is a baby
is an irrelevant one because the bottom
line is that this will become a full
grown human being
if left unimpeded in the natural course
of things this has an independent
dna okay this is going to have an
independent
human existence so you don't have to say
that this is a baby it's not a baby
obviously
it doesn't have to be a baby it doesn't
look like a baby but it is a human life
and that's what matters
okay and then very quickly there's
implantation that takes place
and then by four weeks by the time most
women recognize that they are even
pregnant
the ball of cells that is supposedly not
human life is now an embryo
okay this is by this point it's now an
embryo and by five weeks
the baby is already beginning its own to
form its own circulatory system
the tiny heart already begins to weak
begins to beat at about
week five by week six and we are now
talking one month of a woman knowing
she's pregnant
by week six the nose mouth and ears are
starting to take shape
the intestines and brains are beginning
to develop
hey by week seven the baby has doubled
in size since the last week
little hands and feet are beginning to
emerge by eight weeks
breathing tubes are extending from the
throat to the developing lungs nerve
cells are branching out
forming those primitive neural pathways
and this is when people start to make
the arguments about whether babies can
feel pain or not
at nine weeks the baby's basic
physiology is in place
if the baby continues to gain weight by
week 10
the skin is translucent but tiny limbs
can bend details like fingernails are
beginning to form we can tell the sex of
the baby
at this point this is when most women go
into the doctor and the doctor
does the ultrasound and then you can
tell whether the baby is a boy or a girl
okay all of this is happening within the
first two and a half months of pregnancy
all of this is happening within the
first trimester and yet the democratic
party platform position is that this is
not a full grown
this is not it doesn't matter at all
right there's no moral component
of aborting anything anywhere in here
and all the way up to birth all the way
up to birth there is no moral component
that's an incredible science-free
argument and yet that is the argument
that's made we are called the science
deniers if we dare to mention things
like
biology basic fetal biology
you know you know who actually
acknowledged that taking a human
abortion was taking human life is
actually the founder of planned
parenthood
margaret sanger said abortion was the
wrong way no matter how early it was
performed it was taking life
it was only later that planned
parenthood became not a contraceptive
center
but an abortion center alrighty so
the second argument the second argument
uh with regard to the pro-choice
position is that this baby can't survive
on its own right we should be able to
abort it because after all it's hooked
up to another human
and because it's hooked up to another
human viability is the real test
peter singer who's an ethicist an
ethicist at princeton university which
tells you everything you really need to
know about princeton university
he acknowledges that this makes no sense
really he acknowledges that it makes no
sense because
most babies are not viable in the sense
that they can survive on their own for
several years after they are born
i have a two and a half year old son
right now he cannot survive on his own
legitimately like if i were if both my
wife and i were to abandon him in the
house
he would stick a fork into an electric
socket within minutes
right this is this is what small
children do and this is particularly
true of infants right if you have an
infant
the infant requires constant care the
infant constantly requires
that you are feeding it and taking care
of it and changing it
the viability argument makes no sense it
doesn't even make sense when you're
talking about many older americans who
require constant care in places like
assisted living facilities
so the viability argument that if you
are dependent on another human being to
help you live you are therefore not a
human life
obviously doesn't hold which is why
peter singer he actually acknowledges
this he says
opponents will respond that abortion is
by its very nature unsafe for the fetus
they point out that abortion kills
a unique living human individual that
claim is difficult to deny because again
this is a separate
human being so what he says what he says
is that killing a newborn
is not equivalent to killing a person
because that
because what you really need the
standard should be self-consciousness
or autonomy or rationality but none of
those hold up to scrutiny
none of those hold up to scrutiny now
the reason none of those hold up to
scrutiny is a standard for viability
autonomy
self-consciousness rationality is that
again babies do not have any of these
things
okay so if that's the case then you
should be able to commit infanticide and
in fact that's actually what peter
singer says he says you should be able
to commit advance aside
on kids after they're born at least if
the pro-choice position were to be
consistent
they would have to acknowledge how evil
that position is full scale
okay argument number three is that it's
responsible to abort okay this is the
argument that women
are making a responsible decision when
they take the life of an unborn child
because the child will probably be
miserable anyway the kid will probably
be
upset day-to-day might be depressed
might be obese
for example i don't know if you've seen
this video there's this woman who's been
trying to go around training
small children to be pro-choice she's
she's
this woman who works for shout your
abortion and she explains to a kid
that she had an abortion because she
just wasn't ready for a child as though
this is some sort of
moral stamp of approval here's what she
had to say why did you have an abortion
a few years ago i got pregnant and i
really didn't want to have a baby may i
ask what happened did he not wear a
condom did the condom break
was it pre ejaculation
such good questions um yeah
he wasn't wearing a condom why wasn't he
wearing a condom
have you ever had two options and one of
them like
seems easier at the time oh yeah yeah
you could take a shortcut
or you could go the other way version oh
so it's inconvenient
and then it was inconvenient to raise
the child see it turns out that it's
actually very difficult to raise a child
it's time consuming it's difficult
because it's also the most important
thing you do in life and i know that
it has become unpopular to suggest that
the most important thing that you are
going to do in your life is raise your
own children
that you're going to bring a child into
the world and then raise that child to
be a good human being
but that happens to be the truth there
is nothing moral about the idea that you
think you're going to be a bad parents
you get to kill the child
it's an insane argument right and by the
way again an argument that holds true
after birth
what happens if you discover by age four
that you're actually a terrible parent
do you now get to go and drown your kid
in a river somewhere that's not the way
this works
your failures as a parent do not allow
you to kill another human being
okay argument number four is that it
makes life better for women abortion
makes life better for women and this is
the argument that you heard barack obama
express a little bit earlier
this argument that women's freedom is
necessitates the killing of the unborn
there's an article over at the guardian
by a woman named hadley freeman came out
last june in which she talked
specifically about how
the title of the piece is an abortion at
the age of 23
gave me freedom and she talks about how
when she was 23
her life forked just until then it had
felt like one of those la freeways with
half a dozen lanes i had options in
terms of with pat which path i took
but they were all going in the same
general direction i was barely making a
living and a job i enjoyed
living in a dump with friends don't life
was wide open then one day i took a
pregnancy test
and she says that she had an abortion
she says i absolutely could have had
that baby
i would have had to give up my job and
move back in with my parents my
relationship would eventually ended
and it would have taken years for me to
be able to support myself and my baby
but
sure i could have done it but she's
happy she didn't
because now she gets to work the job
that she wants
and she doesn't have to live with her
parents yeah you know who didn't get to
live
someone else and there's a dismissive
view
of the amazing gift of child bearing and
child brewing to begin with i mean the
idea that human freedom that female
freedom is based not in raising the
child but going working 2200 hours at a
at a law firm is just it's ridiculous
and i speak as a person
whose mother was a working woman my wife
as everyone knows is a doctor right we
are
i'm very much in favor of women in the
workplace but if you give my wife the
choice between what's more important to
her raising our two kids
or working as a doctor which is a pretty
important job she would make that choice
in a heartbeat that's not that's not a
difficult decision
what we have done as a society by
devaluing mothering
in favor of work is we have suggested
that freedom itself is tied into work
and not into mothering and that is just
not true
it is just a lie and if your freedom
comes at the expense
of the life of another human being then
it's not really your freedom that is the
top priority
okay argument number five is the
argument that because
rape and incest are really bad therefore
abortion is okay not only in those cases
but in all cases now
this is a real red herring that you see
thrown out by the pro-choice movement on
a fairly routine basis you're gonna be
arguing
abortion you're gonna be arguing the
pro-life position they say well what
about rape and incest where we have lots
of sympathy
for the woman because she's just
undergone something absolutely horrific
first of all the first thing that you
should say in response to this argument
is okay
we can discuss those issues and i'm
happy to talk about those which i will
in one second
but first are you willing to acknowledge
that all the other abortions are wrong
because they're not right this is what
they're what they're doing is they're
using an exception in order to destroy
the rule
they're basically saying that because we
have moral qualms some people about rape
and incest
therefore a voluntary abortion for no
reason having to do with rape and incest
is totally okay
all the folks who consistently mention
rape and incest this is not the good
faith argument that happens
between people who are pro-life on these
issues most of the people who mention
rape and incest are instead much more
interested
in abortion across the board the truth
is that only a tiny percentage of
abortions
spring from rape and incest as early as
1987 the alan guttmacher institute
asked women about their reasons for
abortion only one percent of the 1900
women surveyed suggested rape or
abortion
95 of those who mentioned rape or incest
actually named other reasons as well for
deciding to abort it wasn't just rape or
incest
it was other reasons economic reasons so
it wasn't just pure rapist in other
words
it is a minute fraction of abortions
that we are talking about and when
people cite
those abortions as an excuse for all the
other abortions that is intellectually
dishonest
in a massive way politifact right which
is a left-wing source
said that there may have been about 7
000 pregnancies from rape in 2010 in the
united states
total total out of the hundreds of
thousands and millions of pregnancies
that take place in the united states
every year
and this is supposed to be the rationale
for ensuring that people can have
abortions on demand
each year there are about a million
abortions in the united states
okay a million and they are saying that
seven thousand pregnancies resulting in
rape we don't know how many of those
actually end in abortion let's say it's
half
because you got 3 500 abortions what
percentage of 1 million is that not a
high percentage and yet that is used as
an excuse
by the left where we can have no
legislation on abortion whatsoever
now as to the actual morality of
abortion in the cases of rape and incest
as i have said one million times
in my college speeches and when i speak
about this issue there is no one in the
united states who is in favor of rape
and incest
okay if a man rapes a woman he should be
castrated or killed
if a man commits incest if a man commits
incest
with his daughter or his sister he
should be castrated or killed okay these
are these are crimes against human
beings
these are evil crimes against human
beings but one evil crime against a
human being does not necessitate the
morality of committing a crime against
another human being
if somebody were to rape a woman the
woman were to turn around and shoot an
uninvolved third party
we would understand that she's not
allowed to do that just because
something terrible happened to her
and yet unfortunately we've decided to
conflate the two issues out of sympathy
we can all be sympathetic and still
recognize that it is an illogical
argument that the baby should pay the
price for the crime of the father
okay in a second i'm going to get to the
other arguments with regard to
the pro-choice position and then we have
a special guest coming up
okay so argument
number six that the pro-choice movement
makes is that it is their body
and so you see all of these marches
where people are chanting things like
my body my choice you see these big
rallies people chanting this
there's a big rally in los angeles last
year in which people were shouting my
body my choice
and then women were shouting my body my
choice and men were shouting back at
them
your body your choice here's what that
sounded like
okay so a couple of problems with this
particular argument
okay problem with this argument number
one is that obviously it is not your
body that we are talking about when
women say why are you so concerned about
what goes
on in my body my answer is i'm never
concerned about what goes on in your
esophagus i don't care about what goes
on in your kidneys
i'm not interested in your circulatory
system i'm interested in protecting the
living human being that is inside you
right now that is the thing that i care
about
okay then there is the kind of more
complex argument that's made by sort of
the libertarian contingent of the
pro-choice crowd
the bodily autonomy argument so this is
the argument that you've all heard the
the famous
violinist in a coma argument right this
is the argument where they say you wake
up
in a room and there is somebody who is
hooked up to you via an iv
right just a random person and the
person is a famous violinist and if you
disconnect that iv the person dies do
you have an obligation to keep that iv
connected between you and the person who
is in the coma well
this is not a good argument for abortion
for a variety of reasons which i'm about
to go into in a second first of all
if it turns out that the violinist in
the coma we know will come out of the
coma
within nine months and go back to being
a normal full-fledged human being
it's kind of a dicey proposition to say
that you should be able to just pull the
plug on the guy
right because you know that the person
is going to be a full-fledged human
being when you're talking about
an unborn human baby i mean now a baby
born in seven months is much more likely
to live than to die so what you're
talking about is a time delay
in terms of when this person is going to
no longer be connected to you so that is
point
number one point number two unless you
were a victim of rape or incest
you're complicit in the creation of a
child right the entire
basis of the famous violinist example is
that this person is unrelated to you you
had no choice about whether this person
was hooked into your veins
well if you had consensual sex with
someone and got pregnant you are
responsible for the act that led to that
person being inside you
[Applause]
pregnancy is a pretty foreseeable risk
of consensual sex and was for all of
human history
regardless of whether you used birth
control people who refuse to connect sex
with the risk of pregnancy are either
lying or they're stupid
you wouldn't have an obligation to keep
another human being tied into your body
if you were knocked out but if you tied
the person into your body
yourself you probably would right if you
hooked the violinist into your veins and
made him dependent on you
you'd probably now have an obligation
not to remove the the iv
and then there's another problem and
this applies even in the cases of rape
and incest where
where volunteerism is not really the
issue where it was forced upon you
right that you didn't consent to the
bodily connection and that is
that abortion is not just pulling a plug
and this is the part that nobody wants
to talk about
we speak about abortion and euphemisms
all the time abortion itself is a
euphemism
abortion is a word that people think is
antiseptic it doesn't do anything to the
baby
it's the same thing as pulling a plug it
is not the same thing as pulling a plug
if i change the violinist example so the
question is not
he's hooked into you with a a line you
just have to pull the line
but now you have an axe in the room and
the only way of disconnecting this guy
from you is to chop him in the face with
the axe
that changes the math a little bit
abortion is a violent act it is not
merely the disconnection of you from the
baby
and then the baby dying on its own terms
that is not what we are talking about
here what we are talking about the
process of abortion
involves the dismemberment of an
incipient human life that's what it is
okay finally your child regardless of
how it came into you is your child
the reason people like to use the famous
violinist example is because
the violinist is unrelated to you
they're a stranger even if god forbid
something happened to you that resulted
in a pregnancy not of your choosing
that is still your child if i said to
you that your child were forcibly hooked
into you
and you didn't have anything to do with
it right if i said that if you had a
child you didn't know about and that
child was forcibly hooked into you
wouldn't you have more of a moral
obligation to that person than to a
stranger
you probably would okay argument number
seven that the pro-choice movement uses
is that it's all about safety for the
mother that safety for the mother is the
key thing
this of course is utterly untrue and
there's no science to back this
whatsoever
first they argue that abortion is safer
for mothers than pregnancy because the
process of pregnancy
is likely to lead to more complications
and health problems than
abortion would but that's true of a lot
of things in life
right it's safer for women never to have
to leave their homes but we don't
grant women the right to engage in
identity theft in order they can steal
someone's credit cards they never have
to leave their home
once we're in the business of allowing
some people's right to health to
overcome other people's right to life
we're in seriously dangerous territory
it's always easy in life to say you know
what would be easier
you know i they're dangerous
neighborhoods in washington dc
maybe you should just go kill everyone
in these neighborhoods to make it safer
for you to walk out your front door
that's not the way that this works you
do not get to change
the rights of other people because it
makes it safer for you
the entire argument is that the baby has
its own rights because unborn children
do in fact
have their own rights it's also true
that the number of cases in which
abortion is medically necessary again is
extraordinarily low
if i mean it's questionable as to
whether these cases really exist
even in cases of you know pre-eclampsia
and toxini and late-stage pregnancy are
extraordinarily rare and
in those cases usually c-sections are
actually the best medical solution
not dismemberment of the child and
virtually everyone who is pro-life
agrees with the idea that if the life of
the mother is in danger then abortion
can be considered
but when people on the left say the
health of the mother now they're talking
about just the comfort of the mother
because the truth is we all undergo lots
of health problems all the time now
you'll see cases that the left will use
again using the outlier to
dispense with what should be a general
rule when ireland
recently and tragically decided to
reverse its position
on abortion they cited the case of a
woman named savita halapanova
in 2012 she died supposedly for lack of
abortion
but three official investigations
actually found that this woman
died of sepsis which is a blood
infection that is caused by virulent
bacteria
and if doctors had identified that
earlier abortion would not actually
either have been necessary or it would
have been performed to save the life of
the mother
so when folks talk about how abortion
laws prevent
people from from having healthy
pregnancies or having healthy lives
it's just nonsense okay argument
number eight is the slippery slope of
control so we see advocates for planned
parenthood marching around in their
outfits based on the handmaid's tale
as though all of the pro-lifers want is
to restrict women to the bedroom so we
can forcibly impregnate them
and then call them things like of ben
like this is this is what we're
desperate to do
i mean no offense to the people marching
in the women's march
but don't flatter yourselves ladies okay
that is that is not
high on the list of priorities for
pretty much anyone
okay so the basic argument is that if we
don't allow women to kill their unborn
children
soon we will use them as pregnancy
surrogates by force the slippery slope
is that if you don't get to kill a baby
that you are complicit in creating then
i am going to come in your house rape
you and force you to bear the child
that's a hell of an argument and really
if that's if that's the way you feel
about things then you should forcibly
imprison everybody who politically
disagrees with you because these are all
incipient threats
to your actual to your actual honor
right what's really bizarre about this
argument is of course nobody is forcing
women to get pregnant
and we on the right are significantly
more in favor of punishing rape
stringently than folks on the left
the folks on the left seem to be okay
with letting people out of prison for
rape after five years folks on the right
are a little less okay with that right
whenever there's a case of a
woman who's raped and the father who
then goes and shoots the rapist
conservatives
are secretly and openly cheering when
that happens
it is people on the left who are
generally saying oh that's just that's
just terrible how could the father do
something
like that okay also
you know the idea of forcing women into
being surrogates
surrogacy can be useful and wonderful in
some cases but
let's be real about this surrogacy is a
privilege of rich hollywood leftists
the people who are using surrogacy the
most often are 40 year old actresses in
hollywood
who didn't want to get pregnancy because
they wanted the flat tummy until they
were 40. and then they decided to find a
guatemalan lady and
have a circus and have a surrogacy right
so the idea that this is a widespread
problem
is just not true it's first of all
surrogacy is not all that prominent
second of all surrogacy is itself not
really an issue it's not a moral issue
and third of all no one is doing this
like where are they getting this
we're all going to invade their bedrooms
it's just absurd okay
argument number nine is the
overpopulation problem we should kill
lots of babies because there are too
many people
already first of all this has always
been untrue the malthusian argument
that there are too many people has been
disproved over and over and over again
as there are more people there is also
additional productivity they're more
geniuses they're more people creating
awesome new products and services
there are lots of people who are
creating great things right
there was a bet between paul ehrlich
back in the 1980s between paul ehrlich
who's
a environmental scientist philosopher
at uc berkeley he also happens to be
adult and
and julian simon who's a professor at
university of maryland and the bet went
like this
paul simon uh so so julian julian simon
said to paul air like
you pick any three commodities any three
and i will make you a bet that within 10
you can pick any of them that within 10
years the price of these commodities
will have gone down
the reason he said this is because
additional creativity will create
additional productivity
for these particular products now paul
ehrlich's case was there more people
more people means more demand more
demand means less supply available to
more people so prices will go up
julian simon won that bet because with
additional people
comes additional beauty in the world
comes additional creativity
comes additional brilliance
also again the argument doesn't hold on
any logical level
right if there are too many people in
the world right now which million or
billion would you kill off
if you're really that worried about
about overpopulation to the point where
you think that overpopulation
is a threat to humanity as a whole then
we better start picking out who exactly
we're going to take out back folks on
the left don't really like to talk about
that sort of thing because they
recognize how evil it is but
if they're casting aspersions at people
who can't defend themselves who don't
have a voice to speak for themselves
then it's completely different finally
argument number ten this one has become
popular in recent years after the book
for economics
came out that argument is that abortion
lowers the crime rate
right that all the that what has lowered
the crime rate traditionally has been
killing all the would-be criminals
first of all okay that i don't know
who's comfortable
with the pre-crime version of humanity
where we get to decide
before you're born whether you're likely
to be a criminal and then abort you
based on future criminal activity
in which you have not participated right
the argument i guess here is that would
you kill baby hitler and the truth is
that no pro-life person on earth would
kill baby hitler
right because baby hitler wasn't hitler
adult hitler was hitler baby hitler was
a baby
and what you'd presumably want to do
with baby hitler was take baby hitler
out of baby hitler's house
and move baby hitler into a better house
where he would not grow up to be hitler
right
that's the idea but it is also true that
the crime statistics do not even match
up
criminologist barry latzer points out
that abortions became available in 1973
under roe versus wade
those young people would go on to create
a massive crime spike and the crack
cocaine epidemic but if you move forward
15 to 20 years
right which that's when you would see
the crime drop due to the abortion of
babies but there is no crime drop
you'd expect the absent babies right the
babies that were killed starting in 1973
not to be around carjacking people but
it turns out that people were still
carjacking people
15 years after roe v wade 20 years after
roe v wade the crime the crime spike
only began to drop in 1994 a solid 21
years after roe v wade was actually put
in place
that can't be due to abortion right
that's really due to
additional policing so it doesn't even
match up statistically
now in all of this discussion i've
refrained from discussing the bible and
religion
now one of the arguments that i've made
is based on the bible or religion now
media will pretend that i didn't make
any of these arguments that it's all
about the bible and religion
because the left prefers to believe that
religion is stupid and people who
believe in religion are stupid people
believe in god are idiots and that's the
reason why we prefer to
to protect the lives of the unborn but
we do have to recognize one religious
root to every argument that i'm making
and that is the innate value of human
life
that is a religiously based argument
the system that produces both science
and the enlightenment is rooted in
biblical values
a judeo-christian system created a
system based on science
science only rose in the west because it
was based on the idea that you live
in an understandable universe created by
an all-knowing god
and that that all-knowing god wanted you
to investigate that universe that you
could understand
science so you could understand the
worlds around you that same creator also
gave us the most important verse in the
history of humanity that human beings
are made in the image of god
without that fundamental assumption
without that fundamental knowledge
none of this matters and no policy
argument matters forget about abortion
no policy argument matters without the
acknowledgement that every human being
has value once you accept that every
human being has value can no longer be
quote unquote pro-choice
using their euphemism you must be
pro-life because if every human being
has value
if every human being has value then that
means that every human being deserves to
be protected
no matter how small no matter how early
all of them deserve to be protected
because they are innately valuable
now thomas jefferson thomas jefferson
said about slavery can the liberties of
a nation be thought secure when we
have removed their only firm basis a
conviction in the minds of the people
that these liberties are the gift of god
that they are not to be violated but
with his wrath
indeed i tremble for my country when i
reflect that god is just that his
justice cannot sleep forever
god's justice will not sleep forever and
we're not going to sleep until we see
justice done we'll choose life so we and
our children may live
all right well i want to bring on the
program right now a very special guest
vice president mike pence thanks for
joining the ben shapiro show
thank you ben it's great to be with you
thank you for being at the 46th annual
march for life and thanks for being a
leading
voice for life in this pro-life
generation
as you can tell i think the folks over
here like you vice president pence
we're really excited to have you can you
talk for a couple of minutes about the
importance of the march for life why the
march for life matters and why this
issue ought to matter to all americans
well it just uh you know it it is an
extraordinarily important event you
think 46 years ago this month
a majority of the supreme court of the
united states
turned its back on the unalienable right
to life and here
nearly a half century later generations
of americans
have come together to say no we are
going to put
the sanctity of life back at the center
of american law and i believe in our
lifetime we
will accomplish that we will stamp
surprise in america
well vice president pence i wonder if
you could talk a little bit about what
the trump administration has done to
protect human life this is one of the
more glorious parts of the trump
administration's record maybe you could
talk a little bit about what you've done
legislative and
in regulatory fashion to protect the
unborn
well it is you know you know our family
and
you know my my kids are big fans of
yours like all the great young people
listening
this morning at the march for life and
around the country um but you know the
uh
since karen and i entered public life
we've stood for life and i couldn't be
more proud
to be vice president to the most
pro-life
president in american history president
donald trump
you look at the record of this
administration you look at
the from literally the first days of
this administration the president
reinstituted
the mexico city policy that had been
overturned
by president obama now no federal
tax dollars go to any foreign
organization
that supports or promotes abortion
around
the world
it was my it was also my great honor to
cast the tie-breaking vote
ben in the united states senate that
allows
states across this country to defund
planned parenthood
and president trump president trump has
kept his promise to the american people
appointing in the last two years a
record number of conservative
men and women to our federal courts at
every
level who will uphold all the god-given
liberties enshrined
in our constitution and that includes
justice neil gorsuch and justice brett
kavanaugh
[Applause]
so we've got we've got a record a record
of
extraordinary progress on the right to
life
and uh it's my great honor to serve in
this administration but i i must tell
you ben that your voice
on the airwaves across the nation your
presence at this march for life the
presence of this
pro-life generation that will gather on
the national mall today
gives us great great confidence that
this
will be the generation that restores
the right to life in america and i thank
you
vice president pence i want to ask you a
little bit about some of those threats
because
this obviously is a battle and it's an
ongoing battle we've seen just in the
last week
unfortunately a house democratic caucus
has decided to try and raise the issue
of the hyde amendment the more radical
members of the democratic caucus want
federal funding directly for abortion
they're trying to reverse president
trump's policy
on the mexico city policy what do you
see
as as the chief threats to the right to
life moving forward as unfortunately one
of the parties becomes more radical on
this issue
well look the uh the the
the american people elected in 2016 a
pro-life president and pro-life
majorities in the house and senate
we made great progress we actually
expanded
the pro-life majority in the united
states senate
in the 2018 elections but the democratic
party
the party of abortion on demand as now
has a majority but i can promise you
that our pro-life colleagues on capitol
hill and this pro-life president will
stand
in the gap we will uphold the hyde
amendment
and we will stand up for the right to
life against all of their efforts
well vice president pence i know that
you have uh a busy schedule today but i
do want to ask you
beyond the march today what do you hope
that everybody takes home from the march
and what would you like to see everybody
do when they get back to the towns and
cities where they live
to help continue to push for pro-life
positions and try to protect the lives
of the unborn
well my message to each one of them is
first and foremost ben and really to you
is to say thank you thank you for
standing for life
it takes courage in this day and age to
stand up for your values
and my word each and every one gathered
there and all those listening around the
country is
continue to stand firm to be prepared to
give the reason
uh for your your devotion to life for
the hope that you have and
be prepared to defend life but do it
with gentleness and respect
and love the progress that we have made
[Music]
[Applause]
the progress that we have made in the
last 46 years has been driven
by by the stand for the unalienable
right to life that millions of americans
continue to take and have taken
but but it's also i truly believe been
demonstrated by the faith and the
compassion that's been shown
for women in crisis pregnancies i met
yesterday with students for life an
incredible
organization and i met with young
mothers
who had babies on their knees they had
gone to crisis pregnancy
centers and instead of facing judgment
they
they were met with an embrace they were
met with love their practical needs were
met
and they were able to choose life and so
my my word to all of those there
is to continue to stand strong
continue to stand firm continue to make
the case for life but always
make it with love and gentleness and
compassion
and when we continue to do that i truly
do believe
that we will once again restore the
right to life
to the center of american law well
mr vice president thank you so much for
taking the time i know everyone here is
grateful for you taking the time and we
are grateful for everything the trump
administration has done
to protect life we hope to see you here
next year as we've seen you here in the
past really appreciate the time
thank you ben thank you for being here
god bless you all
vice president of the united states mike
pence what what an amazing thing the
fact is that
i do think that in the end our movement
is going to win i think that it will win
because i think that science is moving
in the direction of our movement i think
as more and more people see the facts as
more and more people see the science
they will be convinced and i think that
as more and more people search for
meaning in their own lives and they look
for a purpose to existence
and they look for a rationale for
getting up in the morning they're going
to recognize that their own lives matter
and if their lives matter so do everyone
else's lives
and those lives include the lives of the
unborn
okay time for a couple of things i like
and then a thing i hate
so i'm gonna do something that i have
never done before so i do not put
pictures of my children
online uh i just don't do it uh because
you know i'm unfortunately a target i
get a lot of hate
a lot of people who despise me uh but
what i can do is my kids are now old
enough that if i show infant pictures of
them they would not be recognizable
because babies when they are first born
do not look anything like they do now my
kids are much cuter now
than they were in these photos so i want
to show you the things that i like are
the things actually that i love the
things that i care most about
in my life my nearly five-year-old
daughter and my two and a half-year-old
son
this is a picture of my my daughter if
you have
her if we have her picture but there's
my daughter shortly after she was born
uh this is a couple of weeks after she
was born she is a beautiful child
yeah she does look like me right because
she's my kid i mean that's how it works
right
uh and uh and then here is a picture of
uh
of my son and we go back to the other
one this is him he's uh he is just again
an adorable adorable kid
now i was there for the i was there for
the birth of both my kids and
when folks say that the greatest day of
your life is the birth of your children
this is obviously true
it is a miracle every human life is a
miracle and the birth of those human
lives is clearly a miracle
and when when i was in the room and you
realize first of all
the immense incredible unbelievable
responsibility that falls on you as a
human being
to now take care of this newborn
when you realize that the entire future
of the species the entire future of
humanity the entire future of meaning
the entire future of the universe really
does rest in the child that is in your
hands because
without human beings then honestly this
is just a giant rock floating through
space
the innate value of human beings you
hold that innate value
in your two hands and you realize that
this innate value did not begin the
moment that it entered your two hands
this innate value did begin at
conception it began
at the very beginning it began long
before you were ever able to see this
child or hold this child
but it did begin and once it began we
have to
we have to recognize that if you just
had a rewind button on life
if you had a rewind button on your own
life and you just hit that rewind button
the movie begins the movie starts at
conception it doesn't start
later it doesn't start at birth it
starts at conception
at any point at any point god forbid
then or later that movie could end right
that movie could end but
if you end that movie five minutes into
the into the movie you have still ended
a movie right the movie was ended
right you have now terminated it you've
killed something you've ended something
and you've
not only destroyed that human being
you've destroyed everything that flows
from that human being because
i hope one day that i'll walk my
daughter down the aisle i hope one day
that i'll stand there as my son performs
the marriage ceremonies under the chupa
i hope that i'm there for all of those
things because
they're going to carry that on to the
next generation when we stand here we
are standing with generations that have
not yet been born
okay those generations are going to be
the ones who hopefully will never have
to march
for this cause because it will just be
taken as granted
they are part of this great chain of
history this great chain of humanity
that they are carrying forward the
legacy of life and meaning in the world
so the things that i like are the things
that i love and i think they're the
things that we all love and if we don't
love those things enough
then we deserve what then we deserve
every bad thing that happens to us
honestly because
this is this is the only in the end life
is the only issue that truly matters
more
than than any other issue okay time for
a quick thing that i hate
so i played a little bit of this this
clip earlier this woman who sat down
with a bunch of children to try and
indoctrinate them and sort of pro-choice
nonsense
there's a woman named this is a woman
named amelia
bono and she talked about her own
abortion
and her her statement here is so
counter in not only counterintuitive but
counter all reason logic fact and
decency
uh that it's worthy of pointing out she
says that abortion is all part of god's
plan
this is her statement what do you think
god thinks about
abortion i think it's all part of god's
plan
that's that's smarter than what i said
okay the
the idea that god's plan is for you to
do something evil
i'll tell you you know as a religious
person everything
is part of god's plan right i believe
that when acts of evil happen in the
world
even those acts of evil are part of
god's plan what god has done is given us
the choice as to whether
we are going to be the instruments of
that evil what god has done
is given us the choice as to whether we
are going to be agents for decency and
light
or for cruelty and darkness that's the
choice that god placed before us
so the real question is not what god's
plan is because none of us are capable
of understanding god's plan
the real question is what our duty is
what god wants of us
and what the what reality demands of us
and what reality demands of us
is not for you to justify your own sin
to justify your own cruelty and malice
and evil
by appealing to a higher power what god
demands of you is decency
and justice what god demands of us is to
choose life
thank you so much for being here i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
senja villarreal executive producer
jeremy boring senior producer jonathan
haye
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our technical producer is
austin stevens edited by adam syevitz
audio is mixed by mike caromina hair and
makeup is by jessua olvera production
assistant nick sheehan the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2019